IONS OCCURRED
WOMEN.
I WANT TO ME
EAS WE'RE FO
>>IC THIS HAS HUGE FOR THEIG
AIE PANDEMICHAT THE
J&J E WILL LAE IN T UNITED ESHIH
ROLLOUT BECAUSE IT'S ONEHOIT DOU
STORAGE.
THIS COMMITTEE DEBATED AND HEARD
DIFFERENCUSSEHER WOR 50 WOULD B
.
TE WAS 10 VOTE VOR AND 4 AGAINS
ABSTENTION.
E LL
SOIN TE WITH NEW G LABELS AND P
INSTRUCTIONS.
OGER
D SERIOUS
ALMOST THE E RARONTINURE
AND 50.>> SEVEN REMAIN HOSPITED
EDUCATED OWO RESPOND AND
TREAT CLOTS.
HT OF
D O WEEKS AGLS
CHANGES HOW I EA I FIND TM. V A
EDUCATION OF PUBLID
PHYSICIANS WILL IMPROVE OUTCOME
>> Reporter: THE CR
AND FDA STILNE
ON THECI>> I THINK TNG FEELS HA.
BECAUSE IT'S A GREAT ARROW ID S
QUIVER.
>> IT MAY BEY GOOD AND
IN SOME LY
R PAE MIGHT FUE HESITANCY AND SG
NAMES ON BOARDO SUCH
FEARSOOU
AND I THK ATE SOHR
I'M JUST TRYING TO HELGET US
THWE'VE GO
FIRST TIME IN A COUPLEWE WHILEES
ENY IT WON'T BE T NEITHER WAS G
KIDS GET A SHOT.
>> I'M QUITE HOPEFUL THAT
HAVE A VACCINE
A A
MANUFACRS PRE
FOR A BOOSTER SHOT.
>> LATE SUMMER A FALL.
THAT BOOST OF ANT.
>> MEANTIME,GE DLY
VIE
CONTINUES TO FALL.
WTINUTOTEICANS, WE'LL CONTINUS
RIGHT DIRECTIOBUAN'T
AFFORD TO LET UP. NOW ONE OF TH
ESF THIS MEETING
THESE POSSIBLE CLOTSO
THE CDC SAYS T SYMPTOMS
A LITT.
HEADACHE MIGHTE KEY.
NOT A HEADACHE THE DAY AFTER THE
VACCINATION.
TH CFOR BENIGN ADACHE AWO
AFTER THE ADNT
SHOULD GO R PHYSICIAN AND
WOLF. HEM THATOUE HAD THE
>> NICK, THANKRYWAG INNDR EA WEE
NOW.
WHAT ARE YOU PICKING UP OVERE H?
>>
QN AS THE WHITE H
IS KIND OF
HALF.THEY ARE NOT RLLN
THIS DEC'S UP TO
E D FDA. THIS IS AECISION THAT
DR AND  CDC DIRECTOR
AS THEY ARE WAITING  CDC ON VAC.
TO MAKE THIS DECISION, THE WHITE
HOUSE IS READY T FOR THICAUSE TN
THE JOT THAT HAVE AEA
DISTRIBUTED TO STATES AND THOSE
IBERRITORIES ANDE FEDEHAT THE
WHITE HOUSE HAS RECENTLY BEE
USGE
VACCINATED SO IF THE DOERD WITHN
RECOMMENDATION THAT THEY GOT
FROM THIS OUTSIDE ADVISORY
PANEL, WOLF, THAOOAS
TOMOSEEING PEOPLE
JOHNSON & JOHNSON AND SEE IT
BEING RESUIN 50 STATES.
RECOMMENDED THAT THEY STOP USIN
AGO ALL 50 STATES FOOWUIT
AND THE WHITE HOUSE, OF COURSE
T THEM IA
SCRAMBLE AS THEY WERE TALKG TO
RNY THIS WAS
HAPPENING ANWH
WG TO B
A OF
AIDES HERE AT THE ARE WORKIN THT
ED HARD TO TRY
EEBECAUSE,
WERE CONCERNS
ABOUT E TRP
ADMINISTON
COURSE, E BIG ESTION IS HOCTWHAW
DANUMBERS AND THE NEXTHING THAT
WHICH ININDEED.
>> I KNOEY AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
LET'S GET MORE ON THE
NEWS RIGHT NOW
OUR CHIEF MEDICAL CORRESPONDENTO
REJOHN
ON, SANJAY.
OLF, CR  YOUR AUDIA MOMENT.
>> I THINK THAT -- I-- I
LI THE DECISION -- THI
WAS SOMETHINAT
CONSIDERATION.S A LOT OF
TEOP VOTED TO LIFT THE
PAUSE, FOUR PEOPLE VOTED NOT.THA
A TOT
BECAUSE THE
PERSAS INVOLVED IN THE
CLINICRI HAD ALICT.
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE.
A LOT OF REVIEW
WAS TAKING TOO LONG TO COME TO
REMMTHIS IS AN ADVISORY COMMITT
L O LIFTTH
AND TO HAVE G
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT T POSSIBLE
RARE OE OF THESE BLOOD
CLOTS, SENDING A MESGE
TO WOMEN UNDER THEGE
THEY DEVELOMS TOMS ANCTH
A ASSOCIATED WITH THESE
BLOOD CLOT HEADACHE, BLURRED  A
ARE SYMPTOMS THATYY
OCCUR A WEEK OR SO AFT
D TALK TTHEIR HEAL
REROT THAT, AND IT
WAS  A MESSAGE T
CARE PROVIDERS THAMEF OTS ARE VT
THAT WAS I THINK WHAT WEGOING T
IT SOUNDS LIKE THAT'S WHAT'S
LLO OUT HERE. S ARNG BY RD FRO.N
E WI HN
ABARLY 7 MILLION SHOTS, SAP JAO
BLOOCL
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT,
NEARLY MIN? RIGHT SHO
WE PUT THE NUMBERS
TO UNDERSTOW
THIS PROBLEM ANDHEN WHAT THE
DENOMINATOAL, PLE WITHINE RECEIV
IF YOU LOOK AT IT, I THINK WE CE
UNDER THE AGE OF 50, BASICALLY
LEITTHERE, BUT IT WAO
ACAL THIS PEOPLEN SEE THAT THAT
THAT'S ON THE LEFT SIDE OF T GR
, E NUMBF
SP
PREVENTED.
YOU CAN LO
T.
IT'S VERY CLEAR THAT THE
BLOOD CLOTS, TENCH THERE JLOOKI.
IF Y GOMEN OVER THE AGE  50  EVE
THERE'S CLEAR BENEFIT FROMS MS
HOALPREVENTING T.
REMEMBER, WOLF EMERGENCY
USE AUTHORIOTHEY LY HAVE TO SHO
THE BENEFITS OUTWEIGH THE RISKS.
THAT WAS CLEAR AND TS  REALL EY
THAT'S THE RECOMMENDATION.
DRN,A PHYSICIAN, BU'RE ALSO SOM
ON?
>> WELL, I A THAT THE PAUSE IST
BECAUSE THERE WAS A REAL COST O.
THWE A LOT OF PEOPLE
IFGE OF TRONG W VED JOHNSON CCV
50.
IN T EVENT
OCCURRAN OF
THENTS OCCURRED IN YOUNGER
EFFECTIVVACCINES, THE PFIZSED T
AND MODERNA ANI THR
WOMET OUEND  THER WPART OSE I
ISKSHE ALTERNAVE
FOR PEOPLE W D HAVE IVES.
A COUNTRY WHERE HNSON & JOHNSO
OPON O FOROPTION THEVA
MAYBE SOMEE
PHOBIA AONCOND
THEY SHOULD HAVE THE OPTION TOOT